Therapy helps us
understand our emotions
and there's a lot of evidence
to suggest that it can help us
improve our functionality
and quality of life.
62% of patients
with Major Depressive Disorder
showed improvement
after psychotherapy.
But people's views
on therapy are mixed.
Some people believe
that therapy isn't for them.
In Latino culture,
that's just not something
that's readily talked about
or on the table.
They were just like,
"You need to replace
your thoughts
with positive thoughts,"
and that's not helpful.
Fabiola:
While others say...
Therapy has helped me
to be a better writer
and a better lover,
a better son,
all those things.
It's literally been
life-changing for me.
One important thing
about going to therapy
is realizing that
you are in control of
your own narrative.
I look at therapy
like I'm walking onto
a construction site
and I am the product
that we're building.
Everyone's experience
with therapy is different,
and whether someone finds
value in it can be subjective.
But if you look closer,
we might even realize
that our views on therapy
are limited,
since they so often
center psychotherapy
and leave out a much bigger
world of healing.
Therapy was created
from a Euro-centric lens
for individuals that come from
a Euro-centric background.
In a year that was
especially challenging,
the mental health conversation
is more important than ever,
and that got me thinking,
is therapy for everyone?
( theme music playing )
- Hey, y'all.
- Both: Hey.
So, therapy,
was that ever something
that crossed your mind?
I've never really
thought about therapy.
I think I always
thought of therapy
as you pay someone
to listen to you talk
about yourself for an hour.
It didn't really
cross my mind that even
though probably I had
some of the hardest times
ever this year,
that I should go that route.
For me,
talking to a therapist,
just having someone
to share things
that I don't feel comfortable
sharing with my partner,
my family, and having someone
who's non-judgmental
is something
that really has fundamentally
changed a lot for me.
The number of people
dealing with anxiety
and also suicide
during the pandemic
has skyrocketed,
and we know that therapy
is highly effective for that.
For severe anxiety,
in January of 2020,
we were at 71% of people
reporting severe anxiety.
And then by September
it was 80%.
Also, the number of people
reporting frequent
suicidal ideation increased,
but the problem is that
a lot of people just are
not accessing therapy.
I have a report here from
the city's mental health arm.
We see that there's
clear disparity
along racial lines
of who's accessing therapy
and who's not.
58% of depressed white people
are receiving therapy,
whereas only 30%
of depressed black people
are getting that treatment.
- Fabiola: Yeah.
- Lee: Wow.
And so my question is,
in a city like New York City,
why is it still that just
white people are getting therapy
in a way that their black
and brown counterparts aren't?
If I had to guess,
it would be access to it.
On my worst days, that's when
I'm like, "Okay, I need help."
And then I start looking
for help, and then I realize
I can't afford help.
And then, even if they do
take your insurance,
their office
might not be accessible.
On top of that,
your therapist might be ableist.
But not a lot of them speak
a lot of our native tongues,
you know?
Like, a lot of them
operate in English.
It's really all about
what will society say?
The classic, like,
"log kya kahenge,"
like, what's everyone else
gonna say?
So, I want to talk to you
because I know that one in five
Americans lives
with a mental illness.
But about 60% of people
aren't receiving the care
that they need.
How come so many people
aren't accessing therapy?
So, a main one,
not the only, is money.
So, you're thinking anywhere
between $75 at the low end.
I've seen as high as $600
an hour at the high end.
- Wow.
- Let's take Patient A.
Patient A is struggling
with symptoms
that we typically would
associate with depression.
She really would love
to go see somebody,
but her primary struggle
is how to pay for it.
What we know from a study
by the National Council
on Behavioral Health
is that 42% of folks
indicate that money
is a primary reason
why it makes it difficult
to access mental healthcare.
In my journey with trying
to seek out a therapist,
it's always this question of,
"Will my insurance
cover this therapist?"
But my therapists just always
seem to be out of network.
- So, why is that?
- There's a couple things.
One is,
many don't take insurance,
and for those who do,
they're limited
in terms of the numbers
of types of insurance
that they take.
Part of the reason
is this lack of parity
between what you can charge
and be reimbursed for
as a mental
healthcare provider.
There are many providers
who struggle with this idea
of how much
they get reimbursed.
And so what ends up happening
with a lot of providers
is they just decide,
"I won't take
insurance at all."
So, who is Patient B?
What's going on with Patient B?
So, she has money
or she has the right insurance
to be able to pay,
but there is a shortage.
Research tell us that
about 35% of people
in the United States
live in areas where
they don't have access
to mental health providers.
For every 100,000 people
in a rural area,
there are only
nine psychologists.
- Wow. Yeah.
- Which is mind-blowing.
Versus urban areas,
for every 100,000 people,
there are 33 psychologists.
To be a little bit crass,
going into
the mental health field
is not as sexy as going
into some of these others.
People who go
into mental health fields
are sort of at the lower end
of the food chain
in terms of how much money
they're gonna make.
So, who is Patient C?
Patient C is
an Asian-American young woman
who also identifies
as a member of the queer
LGBTQ community.
The trouble is not only
availability of providers,
but providers'
cultural competence.
Because she has
multiple identities,
which we all know now
as intersectionality,
the provider
that she has access to
is not necessarily someone
who understands all facets
of her identity.
86% of psychologists
in the United States
identify as white.
- That's jarring to me.
- If you're a white provider
or, you know,
have any identity
of privilege,
the last thing
you want to do is get
your patient to teach you.
You should be trying
to learn on your own.
So now we are here
at Patient D.
What's going on
with Patient D?
So, Patient D is
an African-American black man
struggling with and managing
Post Traumatic Stress Disorder.
There's always a hierarchy
of healthcare concerns.
Unfortunately,
mental illness being probably
the most stigmatized.
A CBS poll found that
51% of the people surveyed
said that stigma was an issue
negatively impacting people
who were struggling
with their mental health,
people with mental illness.
How the world views people
with mental illness,
more often than not,
is not positive.
Where does
the stigma come from?
So, stigma really has to do
with the perceptions
that we hold,
and it impacts all of us.
I think more so,
though, it impacts
how black people
are treated in relationship
to mental illness.
They're not met with open arms,
"Come, let us help you."
They are literally met with
life or death situations.
So, to understand stigma,
you really have to
look at the history.
Fabiola:
Many communities
battle stigma
around therapy
and mental illness.
Within the black community,
the stigma rises
from a long
and often dark history
of how America has dealt
with mental health.
And I curated this exhibit
to take us through
that troubled history.
- Thank you for coming.
- Christophe: Thank you.
Here are your headphones
for the exhibit.
Cleo: Thanks
- I'll see you at the end.
- Christophe: Sounds good.
Fabiola:
Let's start at the beginning.
For much of the 19th
century, people living
with mental illnesses
were isolated
in insane asylums.
For the few black patients,
they were segregated
from white people.
They were forced
to labor in the fields,
conditions not very different
from life on plantations.
The other black mentally ill
patients were sent to jail
or mental hospitals.
( music playing )
( men shouting )
As the country careened
toward the Civil War,
white people accused freed
black people of insanity
as a means to wield control.
Samuel Cartwright,
an assistant surgeon general
of the Confederacy
invented two mental disorders
exclusively for black people
to explain their tendencies
to flee captivity--
drapetomania
and dysaethesia aethiopica.
His cure was to
"Whip the devil out of them."
By the 20th century,
psychiatrists had started
working on cures
for mental illnesses.
Through eugenics,
the practice of improving
the genetic composition
of the human race
through selective mating,
the government forced
the sterilization
of more than 60,000 supposed
feeble-minded individuals.
This included
promiscuous women,
immigrants,
and people of color.
This one is wild.
This is a Fittest Family
eugenics competition
at the Eugenics building?
You can see sort of
the language of science
being used to justify
whatever political action
comes next.
Fabiola: By the middle
of the 20th century,
psychotropic drugs
became the popular
therapeutic treatment
for mental illness.
And following decades
of overcrowding, neglect,
and abuse in asylums,
de-institutionalization
began in 1955
and resulted in the closure
of state psychiatric
hospitals and asylums.
The re-entry of people
with mental illnesses
back into society
foreshadowed
the challenges they'd face
in the criminal justice system
decades later.
♪ Freedom ♪
♪ Oh, freedom ♪
Fabiola: During the 1960s
Civil Rights era,
as black Americans
led protests for equality,
the American Psychiatric
Association deliberately
changed the definition
of schizophrenia
to include aggression.
Prior to this,
it was described
as a largely harmless,
docile condition
exhibited by white patients.
In 1968, two psychiatrists
described schizophrenia
as protest psychosis,
which classified black people
as hostile and aggressive.
- Protest psychosis?
Holy ( bleep ).
- Wild.
Fabiola: In the years after,
companies marketed
pharmaceuticals
directly to black patients
whom they felt were
out of control.
It's like these are
the modern versions
of the diseases that
Cartwright invented.
It doesn't even feel
like these ads are designed
for people struggling
with schizophrenia.
It feels like they are
designed for fear mongering.
Fabiola:
Deinstitutionalization
and other social forces
such as the criminalization
of substance use
led to an overrepresentation
of mentally ill people
in prisons and jails.
Christophe:
I mean, if 37% of people
in state and federal prisons
have been told they've had
a mental illness,
it's like our prison system
is basically functioning
as that system
of institutionalization
previously did,
but just without
the intention of even
trying to be remediative
or a process of therapy.
It's just about punishment.
Fabiola:
You can now take off
your headphones
for the final portion
of our exhibit.
- Hello.
- Cleo: Hello.
So, I'm gonna walk you through
the final portion
of the exhibit.
If you can just
walk along here with me.
Race has always
been intertwined
with diagnoses and treatments
for mental illness,
so if you're a person of color
categorized as mentally ill
and you've never received
adequate treatment
or adequate care,
that could be
a death sentence.
Daniel Prude, Eleanor Bumpurs,
Walter Wallace Jr.,
Alfred Olango,
Angelo Quinto, and Ezell Ford.
These are just a handful
of names of people
killed at the hands of police
when they needed
mental health services.
So, to close out our exhibit,
I want to end with a statement
from the American
Psychiatric Association.
"Since the APA's inception,
practitioners have at times
subjected persons
of African descent
and indigenous people
who suffer from mental illness
to abusive treatment,
experimentation, victimization,
in the name
of scientific evidence,
along with racialized theories
that attempted to confirm
their deficit status.
These appalling past actions,
as well as
their harmful effects,
are ingrained in the structure
of psychiatric practice
and continue to harm
BIPOC's psychological
wellbeing even today."
I feel like if we become
more aware of how systems
of oppression operate
to disenfranchise people,
that can be
sort of a back door
to removing the stigma to things
that we think are not for us.
It's time to highlight those
marginalized communities
of therapy that we could
really use today,
not only for ourselves,
but I think
for the broader world.
So, where do we go
when the systems
that are supposed
to help us harm us?
Fortunately,
there are therapists
who have been creating
safe spaces to help us unpack
and heal from our traumas.
Woman:
Now you can take in
a nice deep inhale.
As I bathe you in sound,
just sit and take in
the vibration.
Perhaps you can take in
a deep breath,
just to seal the practice.
And when you're ready,
you're going to shift your gaze.
Wow.
- How was that for you?
- That was incredible.
I feel like I struggle
to, like, calm my mind
and quiet my  mind.
And I feel like it's
hard to ignore the sound,
so this kind of helped me
focus in a way.
It kind of felt
like I was escaping.
Like, with each new sound
that you introduced,
it was like it
opened up this level of,
I don't know, consciousness.
This is a part of how
therapy can be unconventional,
and how it can actually
bring in some of these
indigenous practices
that we know have been
really profoundly healing
for our communities
for generations.
It integrates that experience
that is more holistic.
So, one question
that I like to ask everyone
whenever we're completing
the practice is,
how's your soul?
Ooh.
I don't even know
how to answer that
because I feel like
I'm always concerned
with how my mind is doing,
that I don't really question
what's going on with my soul.
I feel grounded,
in a sense,
but not completely,
like, at peace,
if that makes sense.
Absolutely.
The racial epidemic,
the pandemic,
and being a person that
lies at the intersection
of multiple identities
that are marginalized
and vulnerable
really makes it
so that ease is something
that is a little bit
more challenging
for you to be able to acquire.
It's important to offset stress
with self-care practices--
whatever healing
looks like for you,
for you to emphasize that.
There's so many ways that
healing can be introduced
into our lives
that steps outside
of the 45 minutes
that you have
in a therapeutic space.
Therapy could be as simple
as walking,
you know, in a forest,
and energy work, like,
reiki-type of work as well.
You know, I've done a little
bit of yoga in the past.
But, like, that--
it's just not my thing.
I just-- it feels like
I'm too aware of my body
around everybody else.
I think everybody's
open to some level of
holistic health,
whether that be yoga,
meditation, like,
even essential oils,
and, like, you know,
just the idea of self-care.
Humor, like,
just being able to laugh
once or twice a day,
like, really a good belly laugh
helps me tremendously,
as well as a really,
really good cry.
Fabiola:
Different forms of therapy,
whether they support
talk therapy or supplant it,
are finding their way out
to the mainstream.
I'm encouraged
by the mental health
advocacy movement
on platforms like Instagram
that are encouraging people
to prioritize
their mental health
and figure out
the kind of therapy
that works for them.
As for me, I took
Dr. Buqué's advice to heart.
I'm on my way to spend
some time in nature.
I had a number of options
to choose from,
but landed on equine therapy
because I wanted to think
more about the connection
between my mind and body
and how trauma manifests
physically.
I'm gonna be doing therapeutic
riding at GallopNYC.
I'm really excited.
Man:
When you're working
with a horse,
you have to be very in tune
to what's happening
on their side, right?
So, if I come in
and I steamroll you
with my opinions
and my feelings and-- it's just
not gonna work, right?
Because the horse
has his own feelings,
his own opinions,
so I have to partner
with him.
It doesn't matter
the color of your skin,
how you walk in here.
None of those things
matter to a horse.
Being on a horse,
you put somebody on a horse,
a kid on a horse,
that kid is more relaxed
because it's something new.
Never really had
that experience.
Fabiola:
So, how do horses
aid in therapy?
Payne:
Horses can really
feel your energy.
Just their movement
is really helpful
for the rider.
It helps them really
to relax, you know?
She's just coming around
to smell you and say hi.
She appreciates the groom.
Fabiola:
Walk on, Sadie.
- Whoa, back.
- And release. Good.
- Walk on, Sadie. Yay!
- Excellent.
Very nice.
- Trot on.
- There you go.
So nice, firm.
A little bit more pressure.
- There you go.
- Nice.
- And we can walk.
- Walk on, Sadie.
Okay, we'll take
a quiet lap around
so you can
process and relax.
Fabiola:
Just feeling calm right now,
feeling just relaxed.
Listening to Sadie
and understanding
how my different
hand placements
affect her and direct her.
That, for me,
really is about focus
and getting myself
to remember
to be present and mindful.
So, before you get off, I want
you to give her some pats.
We like to tell them
that they did good for us.
- Sadie did such an amazing job.
- Especially if it's true.
I feel so happy.
I kind of want to cry.
She's-- like, seriously,
this was really sweet.
Oh, I'm glad you had
such a good experience.
- Yeah, this was great.
- It's okay.
I feel like such a crybaby,
but I really did feel,
yeah, just a connection,
and she's just awesome.
And this is really
what happens with
the riders every day.
Good, and then you slide.
There you go.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Thank you, Sadie.
I didn't expect to cry
at the end of my time
with Sadie,
but I feel like I got
so much from that experience,
and I fully understand
how therapy can help us
improve our functionality
and quality of life.
But so many people
can't access therapy.
I think black people,
whether we know it or not,
the pain of our ancestors
lives through our body
as much as the beauty
and the joy.
White-dominant society
in general
forces us to be stronger
than we need to be
in a lot of situations.
We're in this moment
in American history
where we're just scratching
the surface of, like,
coming to under--
or acknowledge all of the--
the trauma that this country
has inflicted
on people of color.
Like, the least you can do,
if it's not reparations,
at least give us free therapy.
- Do I think therapy
is for everyone?
- Is therapy for everyone?
I don't think therapy's
for everybody.
Yes, therapy is for everyone.
I think that there is a type
of therapy for everyone.
If we could reshape
the medical industrial complex,
then it could be for everyone.
Fabiola:
But we need to, as a nation,
recognize that mental health
is just as important
as our physical health.
Expanding access
to different kinds of therapy
can help more people
find peace.
So, what else
are you noticing?
I feel like I don't know
what I'm doing.
- Let me start over.
- Pew!
Everyone does this,
by the way.
It's not because I'm short.
- I'm glad you asked.
See what we did there?